It's great to welcome to the program today.
Hedrick Smith, who's the executive producer
of the democracy
belly-up where Hedrick travels the country.
I'm really looking for success stories of
democratic reform, which is, I mean, you know
what I find interesting about this Hedrick
is that there's so much negative going on
and it's not about pretending that everything
is great, but I think it is important to understand
when there are opportunities to make positive
change. We want to understand both what they
are, but it seems a focus for you also is
understanding how they can be replicated elsewhere.
Is that a piece of what you're trying to do?
But you got a bundle of things there. First
place. I didn't actually go looking for successes.
I was traveling the country. I had written
a book called who stole the American dream
about how we got the inequality in this country
and people will start peppering me at my college
lectures and talks with other groups. How
are we going to fix this as any way doing
anything about it? So I really kind of stumbled
into the store and I began to find that there
were people doing something about student
debt, about minimum wage, and then they were
doing something about gerrymandering and dark
money and voter suppression and things like
that. And I said, wow, this is a story and
it's not being reported. And if you're a good
reporter, finding a story that's good and
that nobody else is reporting are not doing
much about, that's what you want to go after.
And I was a foreign correspondent for the
New York times for a long time. Moscow, Cairo,
Saigon, Paris. I learned then you can't cover
a country by sitting in the Capitol. And that's
what our Washington press Corps is doing.
And one of the reasons is the story is really
negative here. It's partisanship, it's gridlock,
it's lobbyist taking over Congress as corporations,
capturing the Congress and people being left
out. But if you get out into Colorado, Washington
or North Carolina or Florida or South Dakota
of all places, Connecticut, Massachusetts,
people are on the move and they're fixing
things. And I just thought that's a tremendous
story.
A lot of the stories you, stories you tell
relate to money and politics in some way,
shape or form. Sometimes it's very direct.
It's literally about money. Sometimes it's
more indirectly related to the influence that
one can buy or wield if they have access to
money, sometimes hidden money in different
ways. Is this the number one theme in a sense
that what we need to be looking at at as a
starting point is the way that money flows
into politics or is there some other theme
that you would assign to the stories that
you found?
Well, I, the most important theme is that
people power works. There's a, there's an
enormous dissatisfaction and anger and disenchantment
among the American people today with a political
system, a sense that Washington and politicians
don't listen to people like me. Uh, that the
big money is captured Congress and the government
is working for special interests. Uh, and
along with that, there's a widespread feeling
of powerlessness, of hopelessness. There's
nothing we can do about it. They've got all
the money. They've got a lock on power. We
can't get them out of office. They won't listen
to us. Uh, and uh, a friend of mine, Ernie
Cortez, who's an organizer down in Texas in
the Southwest said to me at one point, you
know, people say power corrupts. Absolute
power corrupts. Absolutely. He said, but powerlessness.
Powerlessness also corrupts. It corrupts democracy
at the core. But what astonished me wasn't
there is, I don't know, eight to 8%, 10% 15%
20% of people out there who say, dammit, I'm
going to do something about it.
We got to take this on ourselves. That's the
main theme. The main theme is that people
power does work. I mean, last year 20 the
last election, 2018 was the best year for
political reform in this country. In half
a century, five States adopted gerrymander
reform, three adopted elect reform, seven
or eight States made it easier to vote. Four
or five big cities adopted public funding
of campaigns, a Maine adopted rank order voting
there. There are now a 13 States sign on to
change the electoral college. So reform is
actually springing up all over the place.
So that's the main thing. Yes, money is a
big deal, but gerrymandering is another big
deal. Any way people can get a lock on power
either by manipulating election maps or by
using dark money and big money. That's dangerous
to democracy and people are reacting and that's
great.
Yeah. There's been some successes when it
comes to Jerry Mandarin. We saw what happened
in North Carolina. We saw what happened in
Florida. What I'm interested in hearing from
you about this is gerrymandering is extraordinarily
important and impactful, but for a lot of
people who are just through no fault of their
own, they're just busy living their lives.
They're trying to put food on the table, they're
going to work and doing these things. It's
not an issue that as many people are aware
of as maybe should be. What was it that you
believe took place in the places where they've
had successes that created the activism and
the awareness of this as an issue? Like what's
the difference maker with regard to getting
people engaged and saying, this is an issue
we can activate around, let's do it.
Speaking up and doing some of the about it
in Michigan, a young woman named Katie Fe,
28 years old posted a post on Facebook. This
is back in 2017 posted on Facebook that gerrymandering
was going on in Michigan that the state Republicans
in the state legislature had tilted the scales.
And so instead of there being a sort of a
50 50 split in the state's legislature and
in the States delegation to Congress, which
is about what the popular vote was, there
was a real tilt in favor of the Republicans.
So she writes this on Facebook. Within a week
she got 5,000 responses. She set up a group
called voters, not politicians, meaning voters
should draw the lines, voters should decide,
not politicians drawing the map. She understood
that Jerry Manning was stacking the deck and
therefore it was affecting everything else.
It was affecting how they voted on minimum
wage, on student debt, on immigration, on
gun control, everything else.
And what happens is usually people focus on
their issue and that's understandable. There
are certain issues that really grabbed people,
aggravate them, they want to do some about
it. But what Katie Fe and others have understood
is that fixing gerrymandering, fixing money
and politics, fixing voters rights is the
gateway to the issues that you want to get
to. If the system is tilted and stacked in
favor of special interests, then no matter
how how loud you scream, no matter how much
you organized, you can't change it. And I
think that's a real awareness. I don't know
what it is, why they responded. The answer
was a whole lot of people in Michigan understood
what Katie Faiz said and when she finally
lit the match, it struck a spark and there
it went. But it's interesting. It wasn't just
Michigan. I mean it happened in Missouri.
It happened in Colorado.
It happened in Ohio. You know it happened
in Utah and North Dakota. There's a bunch
of 70 year old women who call themselves the
listen to this, the bad ass grandmas of normal.
They're 70 years old. There are half a dozen
of them. They said, we have a corrupt political
system. We got foreign money coming in. We
got lobbyist with too much power. We're not
limiting contributions. They literally passed
a referendum and North Dakota pushed by the
grant passed grandmas. Now, I can't tell you
why it took off. I think the answer is there's
so much tender out there, there's so much
anger, there's so much frustration with an
unfair political system that if the person
lights the right match, it takes off. And
the answer is it's taken off in state after
state. So there's no special magic. Uh, I
think the key is people hanging in there and
people getting over that sense that we're
powerless, we can't do it.
And I think that's the reason why our movie,
the democracy rebellion is really important
because it shows people that in States is
different. As North Carolina and South Dakota,
California in Florida, Connecticut and Washington,
people power has worked. It's not just a dream.
It's not just, uh, what you learned in high
school. It's not just civics. It's actually
happening. And I think when people see it,
they'll say, and the guy says at the end of
the documentary, it's a wonderful line of
guy named Jorge Misoula, who's a Latino organizer
in Miami. He says, if we can do it in Florida,
you can do it in your state. I think that's
the message.
Uh, is there a, uh, or, let me, let me frame
it up in a different way. There are different,
uh, mechanisms through which we can achieve
change. So sometimes it's a voting for someone
different to represent us in a particular,
you know, state Senate, house of representatives,
whatever. There are ballot initiatives that
sometimes have been successful at achieving
change. There are legal appeals, so filing
lawsuits and appealing those up to a high
enough level at which, uh, a change can be
adjudicated. Are different mechanisms more
or less appropriate for different goals or
is there one mechanism that you believe is
most effective?
No, the more arrows you have in your quiver,
they're better off you are the people, the
people, for example, in North Carolina who
were working in the moral Monday movement
in North Carolina, which was working against
a photo ID law that one of the courts said
was targeted with surgical precision to affect
the voting of African American voters. Okay.
So they went to court and they filed suit.
And eventually they won that court decision.
But they also had demonstrations outside the
state. Capitol moral Monday, they started
out with a a dozen or two dozen people. They
wound up at one point with 80,000 people on
one Monday. So they use mass demonstrations
both to show the legislators, the law makers
that they had to respond to public opinion,
but also to mobilize people. And actually
that's effective. Uh, the way elections is
starting to go in North Carolina, it mobilized
people not just for that issue, but it gave
people the idea that if they came out, they
could influence the state government. They
actually want a Conrad, I mean a governor's
election in North Carolina. So that, I mean,
the politics of North Ghana have begun to
change as a result of the protest movement.
So now there's no, there's no silver bullet.
There's no one answer. And matter of fact,
the more techniques that are used, the better
chance of success, a protest movement or a
democracy rebellion has a then if it just
tries one thing,
there are people who will hear our conversation
and certainly with, we'll agree with the outcomes
of many of the stories that are told in the
film, but they will no doubt, still say, listen
at the national level. When it comes to what
we see happening in the white house, we feel
helpless. We see that there are checks and
balances, but they're being ignored. We see
that there has been an impeachment, which
even if it were to go, uh, to the Senate,
would, um, ultimately, uh, be, uh, an acquittal
when it comes to how the Senate would vote
and they feel powerless. What do you say to
people who are concerned about at the national
level, what they've felt has been an inability
despite what Donald Trump has done, no matter
what it is that has taken place, that they
feel as though it's just a matter of either
we vote him out in November or we don't. And
otherwise we feel like we don't have that
much power to affect change.
Well, if you're going to go mountain climbing,
you don't start up by, by going after Everest,
you start with a Hill and your own neighborhood
and you climb it, and then you learn how to
climb a bigger Hill. Uh, I mean, I think the
answer is if you're looking at what's going
on in the Senate, when you're looking at what's
going on in the Congress, those are directly
affected by the reforms that are taking place
at the state level. Now, if Donald Trump is
defeated in November, the reform movements
I'm talking about will have had something
to do with mobilizing people and giving them
a sense of power. Uh, it, you know, politics
is not a light switch. You can't throw a light
switch and say, Oh, well, if I go out and
demonstrate today, I get whatever it is I
want politically. Tomorrow. You've got to
build for it.
You got to work for it. I mean, I mean, Trump's
election, whether or not people like it or
not, was a Mark of enormous dissatisfaction
by at least 60 million American people, not
as many Hillary Clinton, God, but they were
very unhappy with the party. On the other
side. You've got to acknowledge that. Part
of the difficulty is we get so locked into
our point of view that we think, well, we're
right and the other side is totally wrong
and there's no justification there. The answer
is you've got to go out and persuade people.
Well, one way you persuade people is you get
involved in a movement. One of the things
that, that, that is data that has really struck
me about this movement is how trans partisan
it is. When I go into a Colorado or I go into
a Connecticut or I go into Florida, I find
Republicans, independents, and Democrats all
working on it.
If I'm in Washington, where I sit and where
I live and where I've done my political reporting
most of my life, I see it just absolute cleavage.
I see a grand Canyon. There used to be an
overlap in the parties. Politicians, I mean
the political scientists used to do charts
and they actually plotted the votes of the
Democrats in the house and the Republicans
in the house. And they overlapped. And today
there's a Gulf between them. They actually
chart them the maps and they look different.
That's not the case out in the country. So
the place where we're going to get the country
back is out there. And by the way, that's
American history. I mean the civil rights
movement didn't start in Washington. They
passed, uh, the civil rights act of 1964 and
the voting rights act of 1965 after years
of protest at the grassroots.
So if you were sitting at the grassroots,
if you were involved in the Montgomery bus
boycott in 1955, you had to wait six, seven,
eight, nine years before it happened. But
it did happen and you had an impact on it.
I was in Birmingham, I was in Albany, Georgia.
I was in Nashville, Tennessee. I saw the thing
built. What I'm seeing as a reporter today
is the same kind of building. It will yield
results. It is already yielding results. At
the state level, the democracy rebellion is
leading, is getting those results. It will
lead results to the national level. We saw
it with a progressive era a century ago. Women
got the right to vote. We got direct election,
the senators, we've had this kind of period
in American history before we shot it. It's
smart to take heart. It's smart to take inspiration
and not to do what Ernie Cortez said.
Feel powerless because you can't knock the
guy off in the way you want at the moment.
I understand that frustration. Uh, but uh,
politics takes time. I mean, it's a little
bit like watching grass growing. I mean, if
you watch a long, you can't see any change,
but if you were there in the spring and it
was bare ground and you're there in the fall
and there's a lawn, you understand something
was happening. That's what I think is going
on in America today. The grass is growing.
Uh, the, the land is fro, the people are moving.
Uh, it works. It's amazing. I mean, I have
to tell you, as a reporter who's reported
for five decades has been all over the world.
I've reported from 40 countries. Uh, so I'm
amazed at what I'm seeing and I as a citizen,
I'm really encouraged.
We've been speaking about the film, the democracy
rebellion with the [inaudible]
film's executive producer, Hedrick Smith Hedrick.
I really appreciate your time today and I
encourage the audience to absolutely check
out the film. Be great to have people watch
it. I think you'll take heart. It'll inspire
you.